I don't know how to run a business that
needs to perform financially every 90
days because I'm a marathon runner not a
sprinter you got your perspective
[Music]
hello everyone I'm Andy serwer welcome
to influencers and welcome to our guest
Gary Vaynerchuk Gary great to see you
great to see you although I should say
our host because we're here at your
building in Long Island City so thank
you for having us we're thrilled to have
you so let me ask you this very basic
question so how would you describe
yourself say my six-year-old nephew what
do you do um I'm an entrepreneur you
know at its most purest sense I am an
operating entrepreneur who happens to
put out a lot of personal content of
that journey so there is some awareness
of Who I am as a human but at the end of
the day I'm an executive of several
companies that I run vaynermedia and the
Vayner
X holding company of agencies and
service providing companies is really
really really what I do and that's it
it's not super complicated other than
the fact that I decided that it was in
our business interest and in my own
curiosity of what would it be like if
you documented and produced content at a
scale that I'd never see been seen
before around an executive right what
would it look like if Ariana Huffington
when she started the Huffington Post
what if she put out five to ten pieces
of content a day in podcast vlog and
content across all the social platforms
every day of the first six years of that
journey what would that look like and
that's what I decided to do I mean in a
way it's kind of timeless like the
entrepreneur part on the other hand you
couldn't do what you do today say 20
years ago not only that I didn't do what
I do today when I ran my first company
right when I kind of took the reins of
my dad's liquor store in 1998 I think
you know there the cynical part of being
so out and about is the showmanship then
our system the self-promotion I try to
remind people and like look a lot of
times the accolades that I get in
business today people pass off as well
he's internet famous and that's why it's
happening so it undermines my
operational and executive skills and
when I get sad about that in a debate or
conversation with a friend or a foe I
try to remind them like look I was a 22
year old kid who from 22 to 28 grew a
business from three to sixty million
dollars a year and I didn't make content
I wasn't on the Internet
I was an operator I was a marketer and
so yes you're absolutely right not only
could other people have not done it in
the past I already lived an entire
chapter of building an entire business
that had nothing to do with having a
personality attached to it I was just
the operator of yeah it's a pre-internet
and you know yeah you needed your social
skills but you were operating running an
operating business as you said but let
me ask you've got 5.5 million followers
on Instagram 1.8 million on Twitter how
do you do that I mean I always hear
people oh you just create content you
sit there but it couldn't possibly be
that easy well it's definitely not that
easy that would be like saying how do
you become a professional basketball
player you just play basketball like how
do you become by the way let's stay here
for four seconds because it's a huge
platform and I think we're about to help
a lot of people the number one non
conversation going on in today's society
around influencers and other things is
the talent part like now talent comes in
all shapes and sizes your talent may be
that you're a model you're just very
attractive that's right now you know not
me right yes or a comedian or an athlete
or a thought leader I do believe that
education and entertainment are the two
pillars but yes I mean you know back in
2006 I started making wine videos on
YouTube in 2007 I aggressively put out
content on Twitter had the things coming
out of my mouth not been interesting to
people I would not be sitting here with
you right now it's not super complicated
most people have taken some version of
an attempt
to become somebody people know on the
Internet most people you know there's a
set that's very private
most people have taken a dabble into a
LinkedIn article into a nice photograph
they posted on Instagram into a single
YouTube video a couple clever tweets
most people have tried right so what's
the secret of making people engage with
your content I mean it's it's just parts
okay empathy is the secret
I believe I sit at where I am in lexicon
which is I think a winning player in
today's new environment because I'm
empathetic to my audience I put out
content that brings them value not makes
me feel good about myself right how many
posts do you put up a day an instant and
Twitter them and those are your two main
platforms those are the two main
platforms that I myself completely
control LinkedIn Facebook YouTube I've
over the last three to four years
amassed a team of content creators media
amplifiers strategist around my content
but I fully control Instagram and
Twitter and I put out for Instagram
regular posts and probably you know
anywhere between three and twenty five
tweets a day so I'm a big shout out to
you and your team because the train
going by now the fact that you guys
didn't stop it I'm so pumped right now
I'm fired up like I love that but that
is an evolution and content creation
like it literally just took no time like
oh I like these good job go and that's
antithetical so how does the business
model work like I so explain your
company to me is it vaynermedia is that
the entire business vaynermedia was the
first company for about six or seven
years yeah I mean that's just in size
yeah yeah that's an inside stuff for us
we have fun with that but vaynermedia
was the first company after building up
Wine Library and then after being an
investor in Facebook Twitter Tumblr and
having kind of Silicon Valley success I
just started to stop I decided to start
the agency
with a premise that eventually I would
want to buy nostalgic and historic
brands and I would run them through my
progressive consumer centric marketing
model so I started an agency it it grew
very quickly now there's something
called Vayner X because two years ago I
bought pure Wow calm a women's lifestyle
brand we started a mens brand recently
called 137 p.m. then we started as
speaking Bureau six months ago called
Vayner speakers we started a company in
January to service small businesses
because vaynermedia is made for Fortune
500's called the Sasha group named after
my dad which is fun we have a tech
platform called tracer that is evolving
in a separate company so now there's a
veiner X holding company and very
honestly it's really no different than
publicist or Omnicom or WPP or for
people who are watching it just Mad Men
2020 right obviously a hell of a lot you
know I haven't watched the show but I
assume what they've had in the show it's
a heck of a lot culturally better but
it's not Verizon agency right so the
business model works like you have
fortune 500 clients like give me some
names chase Budweiser Pepsi Hulu and
they pay you service fees to make
pictures and videos on the internet and
on television
planters Super Bowl spot this year was
made by this production company that
we're in and ideated creatively by
vaynermedia we are paid to make pictures
videos written words marketing
collateral what's unique about
vaynermedia in today's world is under
the same roof we also then are the media
agency that places the media we buy the
ads on Facebook Twitter YouTube
Yahoo we do the execution that was the
way it was done in the 60s and 70s the
same people that made it also bought the
television then they separated them and
now most agencies either do creative or
media vaynermedia does both I mean a lot
of people say that ad business's dead
the legacy companies I mean certainly
there are a lot
pressures this sort of a new model I
think some things yeah I agree with the
street and the business pontificate errs
that the old models in trouble but I
don't think it's necessarily because
they didn't have media and creative
under one roof I believe it's because
they were publicly traded companies and
they had to make their own numbers and
when you're a service provider if you
only care about your ebody and your
stock price your clients eventually are
gonna feel that and when they feel that
and they feel the negative effects
I actually believe there's an incredible
book to be written similar to like
barbarians at the gate of what the four
or five biggest holding companies in the
world have accomplished in the last
twenty five years which is through
consolidation they have basically
extracted the value out of the biggest
brands in the world if you look at the
biggest brands in the world that have
used the publicly traded agency model
over the last twenty years they've
declined while the agencies have grown
only now are they starting to decline
because the cats out of the bag because
the biggest brands in the world are
starting to look at Vayner and other
independent alternatives and that's bad
for the holding companies so you
wouldn't necessarily live to go public I
am incapable of being a CEO of a
publicly traded company so no we will
not yeah you know I don't know Elan well
enough and I know he's a character I'm
not I'm not incapable because I want to
curse on video I'm incapable because I
don't know how to run a business that
needs to perform financially every 90
days because I'm a marathon runner not a
sprinter right that's kind of refreshing
to hear that you don't necessarily need
this pant but you don't need that for
your employees I mean it's all I mean
there are a lot of private companies
been around for decades and decades
right that's exactly right no I don't
need I don't want the cash infusion to
buy a boat I want to enjoy running a
company and I need independence as a
entrepreneur and so I'm not willing to
give up my independence for four hundred
million dollars up front so you were
running a liquor store yes and the
internet happens I mean how it
did you realize that the internet was
gonna revolutionize let's just say the
business of communication October 1994
you have a date I do I'll tell you why
October 1994 was the October of my
freshman year of college and in 1991
when I was in high school that's when I
started becoming passionate about my
dad's liquor store and I said I'm gonna
open a hundred fifty of these I'm gonna
open the toys-r-us of liquor stores I
remember being a high school kid
thinking and then in October of 1994 I
went into of my friend's dorm room and
discovered the Internet and within ten
minutes I found myself on a baseball
card bulletin board on AOL and I saw
that people were selling and I'm
actually they're not gonna see it but
you're gonna see it these are literally
goosebumps that's this is real
goosebumps and I'll tell you why it
changed my life I can feel you know you
know I mean I'm really getting them
right now so so I'm excited about this
because it was a really transcending
moment like I was I'm a weird kid
meaning I was a true entrepreneur I was
I had an eye for was burly but that was
before
Netscape weight before Netscape I'm not
sure the timing yeah but is that right
I believe yep yep and I just remember
thinking this is it I don't know what to
say
I was like this is it and literally you
know two years later because it took a
little bit of time I launched
winelibrary.com one of the first
e-commerce wine businesses in America
and it changed the course of my family's
wine business so how do you build an
online brand easily you produce content
on the seventh twenty five places where
people pay attention and you produce it
around things you know and you a mass
awareness
I mean snow how did Nike build a brand
they ran commercials they did
sponsorship like it's just a pension
arbitrage where's the interview for me
it means my career oftentimes I
reference Mariano Rivera when I talk
about my career
mo mo was one of the great closers in
baseball history and at the end and so
you're gonna appreciate this
he had one pitch he was solid at
everything else but he had this one pair
and besides Edgar Martinez literally
nobody could hit it and that's why I
think I am I'm good at other things
I'm a good CEO Oh like I can operate
that's why I have businesses I'm very
good at HR I'm good at PR like I'm good
at other things but I am from this is
now me talking about myself but I if you
ask me I think I'm remarkable at
understanding what humans are actually
doing before the masses understand
they're doing it right
I understood that online dating in 2001
was going to be mainstream that wasn't
obvious until 2011 right or 13 or
whenever tinder really took hold right
and so what I mean by that is I built
wine library on the back of email and
Google AdWords in 1997 no liquor store
in America thought it was a good idea to
build up an email newsletter versus the
catalog that they could send in the mail
got it
in 2001 I bought every google adword for
every wine term and nobody was bidding
me up right got it yeah in 2006 this is
now documented thank God in 2006 I
started a wine show on YouTube in
February 2006
I was one of the first people to move
fast on Twitter I have podcast and
linked it like I'm consistently first
and that skill has allowed me to be good
at real estate right somebody bought up
all of Dumbo somebody once bought up
most of Malibu like some people see it
right I see human behavior okay so what
do you see right now
Boise what does that mean that means
that everybody in this room and
everybody who's watching this video is
gonna do a lot more things with Alexa
and Google home and Apple pod than they
think today like what order every single
food that they eat all of it in 13 years
you will mouth in your office in your
home you will say send me a burger or
can you give me a Shake Shack or I want
to watch them alcohol at bar get me my
sprite you want that's right even I want
a quinoa salad and this is where Brandon
comes in
I want a quinoa salad
if you say that to Alexa Amazon now has
a lot of leverage what quinoa salad are
they gonna send you their own private
label is some brand gonna pay $500 to be
the affiliate so you better say I want
sweet greens quinoa salad which is why
brand is about to become so much more
brand has always been the most important
brands about to become even more
important because we're going to an
audio centric lead-gen world not a
visual centric it's gonna be very big
sounds like you I sure do yeah unless
the government gets involved which I
don't know that stuff that's just not
that's above my pay grade
I would buy Amazon stock in perpetuity
until Jeff Bezos no longer runs the
company but Amazon Google Facebook
Twitter they have a lot of advertising
power does that concern you that they've
got so much of that pie of course not
cuz CBS ABC and NBC had that whole pie
because the New York Times and The
Washington Post had all that pie and
Yahoo at one point I guarantee there's
always somebody that controls the pie I
know always people whining about it
that's right Microsoft should have been
broken up IBM should have been broken up
Google like should be broken now feel
like it's the same old game should they
be broken up Facebook I don't think so
mainly because I think that there's
always another young turk coming up and
she or he is gonna destroy Mark
Zuckerberg because Mark Zuckerberg
becomes passive because Jeff Bezos
becomes passive because Bill Gates
becomes passive because people become
passive right they become content
content old curious and other things
different parts of their life sick die
this is run by people yeah yeah hey so
we're in Long Island City we just talked
about Amazon yes what did you think
about that was the city right to like
boot the matter activists right so I'm
so pumped you ask this question good
let's talk about I have no idea
come on man you said you wanted to talk
about that in your punting I'm not
punting okay I'm I'm the reason I just
got so excited is as a guy who speaks
with heavy conviction which could come
across as audacity or ego or
overconfidence
nothing excites me more than when I'm
interviewed when I actually don't know
the answer to something and I can say I
don't know but that's just it so why
don't you know that's the following
because I'm not willing to do the
homework of the collateral things that
happen after the fact right I don't
understand the actual math around my
intuitive nature is when the greatest
company in the world or definitely in
America wants to set up shop that that
has trickle-down value prop what I don't
know is the concessions that the state
or the city does and the arguments on
both sides of the equation properly and
possibly have come like you know actual
value to them
I just haven't taken the time to dissect
it let me give me an example
I believe that TV advertising is grossly
overpriced right I also think that the
Super Bowl is the number one best buy in
marketing so that's a contradiction
within the micro of the macro that's why
I can't answer to yell I see I don't
know right right what do you think about
politicians like Alexandria OKC or
Cortes who says that we should have more
government involved in terms of people
making higher wages you know it's an
interesting question you know I was born
in the Soviet Union
so I laughed when Americans try to paint
you know liberals as socialists or
communists cuz that's Americans that
haven't lived in communism right so
here's what I would say I am stunningly
socially liberal at the same token I'm
an Alfa entrepreneur and believed in
many of the things of capitalism what I
don't like is when capitalism gets old a
K and alpha gets old
and then she or he tries to use their
money to change the rules of Merit
so I discussed it by that at the same
token I have many 20 year old kids
hitting me up and saying Garry you're
rich you should give me your money
so I'm very scared of the slippery slope
of massive entitlement yeah so you know
more government involvement doesn't hit
me well in my alpha player on the field
I'm an entrepreneur it hits me
tremendously well as I'm the human being
and I want everybody to be healthy and
happy to the best of our abilities I
think the answer is always somewhere in
between
the biggest problem I have listen I'm
willing to give up 95% of my earning I
really am let's go to taxes maybe
getting close to that in this state I'm
willing to I just want to be the one who
gives it away mmm right wait a minute
I'm gonna work my face off bleed in
perpetuity and I'm gonna give it to you
and you're gonna decide who got 36,000
votes like let's let's let's let's like
and you've never operated anything in
your life and you're third-generation
wealthy or your ideology and you have no
practical skills like this is not about
giving away money it's about giving away
money to people that have no idea what
to do with it like that starts where it
gets a little complicated so I want
everybody to be awesome and happy and
healthy and I'm willing to pay
unbelievable amounts for it I just want
to see how you're gonna spend it very
few people actually pull the trigger and
even fewer succeed what are the barriers
their talent you know it's disheartening
that means you're just like you're born
you can either play in the NBA or you
know what you know that's a very good
point
I think it's the following my brother AJ
is a better basketball player than me
cuz he's put in more work on his left
hand in his jumper so he deserves it
he's not in the NBA you can be an
entrepreneur the problem is we've lost
sight of being an entrepreneur who makes
137 thousand dollars a year doing what
she or he loves is an amazing life but
right now everybody thinks are gonna be
Mark Zuckerberg so we've become
audacious and ludicrous and delusional
in our entrepreneurial ambitions and so
I think we need a level of
self-awareness I think people are trying
to be entrepreneurs at a level we've
never seen before because the cost of
entry of saying that you're an
entrepreneur in your Instagram account
is very easy it's also cool right now
I'm actually quite scared about that
because I don't want to be the face of
that because I think 95 percent of
people are gonna fail especially when
the economy fails let me say something
straight to camera if you're not a
successful entrepreneur right now in the
easiest time to be a successful
entrepreneur because there's so much
money in the system and the Internet is
that scale you suck
that's some tough love right there it's
the truth this is the easiest time in
the history of life to be a successful
entrepreneur and if you're not and
you're struggling then you're not an
entrepreneur listen I'd love to be
playing for the Jets and the Knicks or
be opening the Grammys it's fun sounds
rad just not capable doesn't mean I
can't sing better doesn't mean I can't
be a better football player backyard in
Central Park you got to put in the work
and you have to be self aware of your
upside the other thing is we have too
many students who now think that
entrepreneurship is cool if you weren't
selling lemonade and baseball cards or
pogs or burning CDs and flipping them in
school like if you don't sales DNA or
operational DNA or it wasn't fun to play
store when you were five you didn't
gravitate it towards it naturally you're
gravitating towards it now cuz it's cool
right and I take it you did all those
things all those things and and so did
so many of the people that are
successful as entrepreneurs the same as
singers went to choir the same as actors
signed up for the thespian club freshman
year like it matters the work matters
the talent matters what about you don't
get to wake up one day and just say I'm
gonna start the uber of bananas like
it's just crazy what's going on out
there like just the greatest generation
of fake entrepreneurship we've ever seen
yeah the car it's so easy to just cuz
it's cool and it's true if us said we're
gonna be we're gonna be rappers that's
cool too but very quickly we have to
prove if we can rap I'll be like cool
rap and then you can't you're like
you're not a rapper I could say I'm
gonna be a professional basketball
player well I say I'm gonna be a
basketball player I'm like cool show me
you can't prove to somebody in one
second that you're not an entrepreneur
right right so let me ask you about
being about speaking okay you do
speaking I do motivational speaking you
could call it I mean do you feed you are
you concerned Gary that it's
manipulative of course of course but I
don't think I'm manipulative I think
that people want to make me a
motivational speaker but I'm not
if you go watch one hour keynote on
YouTube listen to what I'm saying I'm
not talking about the secret I'm not
like just listen to the words
I'm motivational in my DNA I'm a rah-rah
guy I'd be a great high school coach you
know I know how I come off but I ask
anybody who wants to throw that cynicism
at me to go read the transcript of what
I'm saying I am the most practical
immigrant operating person you will find
there is no delusion in my optimism
right there is no delusion in my
optimism it's funny that you asked me
that question based on the last six
minutes in this interview if you think
about it right it makes me happy the way
it went I don't think the last six
minutes were like hey and I'm gonna
manipulate it that it's so easy I'm
desperately trying to tell people this
is super hard I'm equally saying how
lucky are we that we can even try our
grandparents couldn't start a company
after hours on a phone right yeah this
is the greatest era of the at-bat you're
not guaranteed to hit a homerun this is
the greatest era of the at-bat that's
cool that makes me happy there's a lot
of people struggling paying for college
loans and they get home at 7 p.m. and
I'm saying to them let me motivate you
to not use Netflix and 2k and beer to
escape your problems let me motivate you
to at 7 p.m. to spend the next 5 hours
to build something for yourself on
Shopify or eBay or Instagram or YouTube
to get you out of your situation got it
yeah it's practical what I actually
believe that my natural showmanship DNA
my shtick that is my DNA grossly
undermines what I'm doing people think
it's why I'm successful I think it's
undermining my upside because people
just say you're oh I literally threw up
in my own mouth when you said I was a
motivational speaker ok I'm sorry you
didn't but but I'm telling you a very
important truth yeah ok I
I get it and I understand I look that
part but I continue to push people to
listen to what
right and I can't change what right I'd
love to be lower but I'm pumped that's
your so how do you prioritize how do you
choose what you do how do you allocate
your time number one my admins rule my
life I hadn't I literally had no clue we
were doing this just now we're doing it
I'm aware like and he like she walked
over she's like you ready I'm like okay
I don't even know is the Yahoo one that
you know like I'm my calendar rules my
life me and my team are thoughtful about
what we booked I spend the far majority
of being the operator of Vayner but I do
use my personal brand as a top of the
funnel awareness to drive my business
right right so bringing value for you
know I'm filming this from my own
content bringing it value to your
platform and then the serendipity of
somebody becoming aware of me digging in
and looking and if so I do use my
personal brand as a top of the funnel
business development tool for my
businesses where do you want to take
this I mean you know where do you see
yourself it's important no no it's very
important i I like being thoughtful of
what I'm doing professionally yeah you
know the two things that I'm most
excited about are the continuous journey
of the ambition of trying to buy the New
York Jets
which is my absolute professional goal
that's right is that serious as a heart
attack
right yeah it's been my goal for my
whole life occurs you know it's funny
I'm not sure and I have no interest in
wasting their time because I'm not
anywhere close yet to the financial
level that I need to be probably do I
put it out there quite a bit
and my path to that is to build
vaynermedia to build the greatest
marketing engine in the world to then
buy historic brands when the economy
collapses so I want to buy tootsie rolls
or Reebok or and then I want to become
the CEO of that so I want to buy
something in the next decade for two to
five hundred million then I want to run
it for a decade and then flip it for
three to five billion and buy the Jets
and then I want to make content that
leaves a positive legacy in allowing
people to you know at least use me as a
context point this is how I'm doing it
take
what works for you and and play some
legacy on the content wow that is well
thought out and clearly defined I
appreciate it
how do you see yourself using your
influence on the world it's kind of at
your core I believe that in 40 years
people will realize during this period
of time that I was at one of the few
unique individuals who had the ability
to penetrate 15 to 25 year-old young men
and was able to reframe their mind of
not being as into watches and private
jets and models and cash but made them
start respecting things like patience
and gratitude and empathy and kindness
and that I will be far more revered
after I'm gone for doing it then I'll
ever be while I'm around doing it Gary
Vaynerchuk thanks so much for talking
with us today and thanks for having us
here thank you I'm Andy serwer you've
been watching influencers we'll see you
next time
great that was super cool I like you
really thank interesting thank you